well Brett ashab is out because he
cannot literally speak I listening to
him on Rogan he was a the whole time and
now apparently he can't do anything
because I've never lost my voice I have
a powerful voice you know we say in the
SEAL Teams right Brian what's that week
jeans ah week teens casual arson it's
funny because you are somewhat Metro I
met you well as funny as I met you with
a bunch of dudes at a dinner and every
guy looks exactly the same you look like
them except for you're just a little
bigger like when I when you got up I
went he's got big hands and he looks
athletic like you were you were you were
just a little more muscular like all
those guys were in shape but they're all
a hundred and sixty pounds and then you
got up and I went last dude looks like
an intellectual he's got long hair he
looks kind of like and then you know and
then he's got [ __ ] but but he's built
like what oh it must lift weights
maybe he got good genetics and then I go
you went to work to go to school oh I
went to the Naval Academy oh and you
were in the Navy we're just doing maybe
I was in the teams yeah how long 14
years wait all right so I'm talking
about Judas in the seals I never would
have thought you were a Navy SEAL you
could not be less you do look physically
sound that I just you don't behave in
any way that way hiding in plain sight
this is like an essential life skill
you're a quiet assassin there and then
on top of that you're a war
correspondent you embedded yourself with
Boko Haram which I want to get into all
this [ __ ] yeah
originally I wanted to call that peace
Poco Loco
but like yeah it didn't fly on the
youtubes yeah that did but I mean how
did you get first of all you're an
American here's the problem you're an
American operative an operator when
you're a Navy SEAL and you've been there
as long as you have you probably were
involved in the killing of Muslims or
people who were quote-unquote terrorists
or whatever and so now this ex-navy seal
gets in with Boko Haram how yeah well
it's good wait let's explain who Boko
Haram is Boko Haram but I believe Haram
in Arabic means bad like yeah Haram they
would say and and Boko Haram is
essentially the the it's a it's a
terrorist a self-identified terrorist
group or self-identified Islamic state
group in Nigeria or in the surrounding
areas that basically believes that all
Western influence and culture is Haram
is bad yeah so Haram probably a more
literal translation would be forbidden
and Boko actually means book in a very
literal translation but that's not
really what Boko Haram means it really
means like the wrong type of Education
so what they are trying to do is a story
that's become all too familiar in the
global war on terror is that they were
trying to establish a Caliphate that
promoted their views and ideology in the
northern part of Nigeria why Nigeria is
so interesting what most people don't
realize is that there are 12 states in
Nigeria that have adopted Sharia law
right so yeah Nigeria is this very
bifurcated society split between Muslims
and Christians ebo and Yoruba mostly or
Hausa a lot of houses in the north right
so there's this Geographic like spread
out there where is the north is very
very Islamic and the the South is very
Christian now the self has its own
conflict that's been raging for years in
the Niger River Delta but as of late the
north has emerged out of this conflict
that has to do with with Boko Haram and
with Islamic ideology and while the
predominant language there is house uh a
lot of the Boko Haram guys don't even
speak Hausa
so Hausa is the official the unofficial
official language of northern nigeria in
the kind of Islamic component of the
country but a lot of these Boko guys
they speak Fulani which is like one of
the language of the tribes in northern
Nigeria and Borno State and so they're
effectively illiterate in their own
country even because they don't speak
Hausa and by the way oil-rich oil rich
in the South but part of the politics of
Nigeria is that like many other places
in the world those gains haven't been
realized by the northern half of the
country so the northern half of the
country rock right more impoverished
where the southern half oil-rich with
you know Exxon and all of this
stuff has kind of and Nigeria is crazy
like it's a place the more time I spend
there one of those places in the world
where the more time I spend there the
less I understand it you know you'll be
yeah you'll be in in Lagos in Lagos
which is this mega city with 20 million
people where every square inch is
occupied by someone and at the same time
you'll head out to you know the ocean
there there's a little island where
people surf like I surfed in you know
southern Nigeria but there's like oil
tankers on the beach and it's very like
post-apocalyptic looking and then you'll
have like rich Nigerian dudes driving
Bentley's into the ocean for fun right
yeah they'll be rolling a rolls-royce
like so there's this like incredible
inequality like you see in much of
Africa yeah I'm so incredible poverty
incredible affluence but the North is a
mess man it's a mess it's an utter
disaster so so 14 people killed in a
suicide bombing last week so that
conflict continues to rage as a former
seal as a guy who was I know a little
bit about you you were involved in
things that you know I mean I've been at
the pointy end of the spear you've been
at the pointy end of the spear you know
military people usually arrive at
military options but I don't know how
well that's working what do we do yeah
well we're we're right in it it's
probably one of the more fundamentally
important questions and you know for for
me as you know spending the last two
decades in service and and thinking
about these issues a lot and covering
them you know serving in uniform you all
so much Harvard ladies and gentlemen
harvest you also went to [ __ ] Harvard
more questions yeah grad school all
right
so shut up now open your ears and listen
no there are no real solutions it
appears that a lot of the kinetic
solutions it's like I
I'll talk about someone a lot smarter
than me who didn't go to Harvard which
is General Stanley McChrystal who's a
great American and he famously said he's
ahead of JSOC right exactly and you know
Stan McChrystal famously said like we
can't shoot our way out of this problem
right meaning like you can put a bun
two pipe hitters like me and my boys
downrange all day long and we can do a
ton of killing but at the end of the day
these are not purely kinetic solutions
and we have to do the non sexy stuff the
the state building the intervention that
like building infrastructure and rule of
law all right you know I spent a lot of
time in Africa and this is like the
fundamental problem there is lack of
governance so you're a you're with Vice
and you decide I'm gonna go and bed
myself with Boko Haram how the hell does
an ex-navy seal or maybe even a current
Navy SEAL get in with those guys and not
get beheaded yeah so [ __ ] this story is
actually like pretty nuts it's like do
you ever have those moments in your life
where like everything you've done kind
of coagulates and comes together like
you're using all the all the tools in
your toolkit right this was one of those
moments so you know the long story short
is when when I got off active duty I
went to graduate school and it was pre
GI Bill started what I studied public
policy and international relations
national security policy
you know stuff in my wheelhouse in my
report if you want to work for the CIA
etc it's more about saying anything bro
I it's more like I had just spent like
you know five years down range being the
instrument of those kind of policies and
I wanted to have a seat at the table
eventually on the other side asking the
kind of questions that you just asked me
so I'm there I'm at Harvard it's
expensive as you might imagine you know
coming off a Navy lieutenant salary and
so part of the way I offset my tuition
is by doing this war correspondent
work-wise in school so Christmas in
Afghanistan spring break Cambodia summer
in Somalia okay all the good stuff right
yeah yeah yeah so I made these you know
many documentaries I was in
correspondent work and that kind of
launched my you know I say I traded my
gun for a camera but that was the
mechanism that got me there was all to
pay for the cost to graduate how did you
how did you make inroads into a group
like Boko Haram yeah so getting to Boko
Haram otherwise is no joke either yeah I
was a Mogadishu is you know your outer
places and planet yeah West and East
Africa yeah
get around but you know I also you know
I'll get back to Boko Haram but I was
deployed there quite a bunch I was I had
the privilege of being what's called a
plank owner in the Navy when you stand
up a new unit they call you a plank
owner you get like a paddle and a plaque
and [ __ ] like that you can put on your
wall
so I was a plank owner at the Reserve
Component for Naval Special Warfare of
Sauk Africa that's a lot of acronyms but
like essentially I helped stand up the
Africa special operations unit for the
SEAL Teams so for many years in my
reserve capacity
I was very act for eccentric in my focus
so it was on my radar I was thinking
about it I was watching you know you
have an intellectual voice like it's a
little nasally I'll take ya I love I
love you're such a walking contradiction
like I really appreciated you if I was
listening to you sound like a tat you
sound like you're a computer guy the
doesn't he he's got a little bit of an a
like he's kind of like his voice is up
here you know that's it guys just as
somebody who studies that jock oh boy
chuckles got to know I brought like
Charlie to channel our inner Jocko I
brought this feels like a commercial
whitey yeah is that his company yes
jockey he sent me a couple cases Jacko's
my first jiu-jitsu coach get the [ __ ]
yeah yeah so he sent me he's like pimp
in this jockey get choco tu bastard yeah
we gotta get him on the podcast Jaco is
yeah he's the best
like Jocko is get after it ah remember
this old computer term WYSIWYG like from
the early days of computing like what
you see is what you get
that's Jocko he is like what you see is
what he's unadulterated like he is just
face everything else warrior I'm sorry
to interrupt I had to say that Keep Calm
so uh so yeah so me and my nasally voice
we started doing all this correspondent
work around the world which is funny you
know hey look I got a face for TV and a
voice for radio that's it all works I'm
just impressed I really am so uh yeah so
so I went from this obscure little
television network called Current TV
where I kind of cut my chops and then I
was corresponding war correspondent at
CNN both domestic and international
and then I moved over I was poached by
Vice by Shane Smith advice and I worked
on the HBO show there and I did a bunch
of bunch of work that I'm super proud of
and one of those pieces was Boko Haram
and the way I got there was really
strange from the old days I had I knew a
bunch of guys who were we say private
military contractors pejoratively he'd
say mercenaries a bunch of like
mercenaries from the old days who had
been contracted by the Nigerian
government President Goodluck Jonathan
paid him you know many dekha millions of
dollars to fight the war against Boko
Haram to kill his enemies to kill his
political enemies this is a problem with
our there's a problem right now in the
Middle East as well I have a big problem
of this because governments that are
oppressive are hiring American American
Special Forces guys who really
understand how to kill and organize and
they're killing III I don't care what
anybody says it does I'm just too
cynical this is this is people in power
using American firepower and and
expertise to kill their political
enemies and that's what it feels like
and there's been a lot of articles
written about it right well I got a
buddy locked up in Serbia right now a
couple dudes just got rolled up in Haiti
which would underscore your point no but
on the African continent there is a long
tradition of using private military
contractors to wage war and in fact the
dudes who I was over there in Nigeria
with were the old executive outcomes
guys that were contracted to win the war
in Sierra Leone all that Blood Diamond
stuff so these are the dudes who were
the inspiration for the Blood Diamond
guy and followed that very close right
so I'm not talking like the same company
I'm talking literally the same dudes I
show South African mercenaries those
guys so they're all old the the guy I
flew within the mi-17 Hind helicopter is
like one of the most interesting dudes
when I was over there one of the most
interesting dudes in the world he you
know teaches executives had a fight
helicopters in South Africa on his on
his downtime and then he imported MiG's
you know for sorry mags he imported hind
helicopters to Africa
was fighting on the ground against Boko
Haram under contract with yeah but this
is all like super shady I'm making it
sound legit no this is like as shady as
a kasher yeah so I there's that much
money in war totally and getting rid of
your political enemies it becomes a
business totally and for good luck
Jonathan like we don't have to like
we've already gone way down the rabbit
hole of Nigerian politics but he had an
election coming up and he was perceived
as having not done enough to fight the
Boko Haram kidnapped all those
schoolgirl right and that's how most
people know it the chibok girls so Boko
Haram kidnapped nobody heard of this
like those girls returned through their
families I mean we spend a lot of time
looking for them when we were really
close what happened ultimately is
they've returned about half of them some
were missing there's like this whole
there's no clean answer they return them
in like like a couple at a time like a
dozen here twenty there most of them by
this point had been married to Boko
Haram fighters and many of them were
like yeah and so have a husband when I
went back to Nigeria they're doing like
this crazy thing which are these
reintegration academies for the women
who had been captives of Boko Haram but
it's a very like blurry line as to like
where they're how they felt and where
they wanted to be as you can imagine
like they you know they're young girls
16 years old married to some you have
two babies now you've been living you
adapt because women have had to be do
that forever you know it's like and
total like sidenote I talk about this in
my work a lot is the disproportionate
effect and impact of violence upon women
in these conflict societies nots and
Nigeria is the classic case study in it
um they bear the brunt so anyways I knew
these dudes from the old days from the
gun-slinging days and they had called me
up and said they were going to do this
thing and I just said like are you
amenable it's having me come over and
it's how I don't know if the boys will
like this they're like pretty camera shy
what we're doing is in an incredibly
like gray area of legality even though
it's at this point basically traditional
on the African continent
but no it's against the law in South
Africa all of these guys to a large
degree reformer Sam deaf South African
National Defence Force guys so I went
over there I brought a cameraman didn't
pull out a camera for the longest time
and I just operated with them just went
out like kind of earned their trust went
on patrol with them and then after a
period of time like they got comfortable
that I wasn't there to burn them and
they allowed me to to film a little bit
from there basically at some point my
cameraman went home it was his first
time deployed to a war zone
did it like a fantastic job but there
was a night where we were sleeping in
one of the tents and the Boko Haram guys
started like lobbing some mortars into
the camp and you know because you're it
so you're embedded at this point with
guys who are but being paid to kill Boko
Haram yeah at this point and then but he
but like you know whatever mortars like
are very indiscriminate and fire very
inaccurate so I the way he describes his
then I just like kind of rolled over on
my vest and like went back to sleep and
he was like [ __ ] this I come tap it out
you know but he did an awesome job he
did an awesome job but so then at one
point I was there by myself
and I had to film myself you know do
everything it was basically like the
ultimate selfie movie right like so from
there once I had the trust of the PMC's
of the private military contractors and
was going out on missions with them that
allowed me to leapfrog to the very front
lines and embed myself with the Nigerian
Army with the very most fringe fobby
portion about moving for an operating
right right because you have to remember
the reason I was the only journalist
there is that the Nigerian government
had banned journalists from these three
states so no journalists were allowed
there in fact to Al Jazeera guys got
arrested trying out they were still in
prison when I was there right so this is
why I actually prisons must be super
comfy oh they're amazing yeah that's
pretty much maybe not five start
definitely no that's where I want to be
yeah I'm from the frontlines fighting
book are on been to a Nigerian prison
that sounds great I spent a couple
nights in a jail cell in Djibouti with
one of my
fellow correspondents that we read Toa
Djibouti is in East Africa kind of a
city-state close to Somalia the big joke
Lake there which got old really quick
was like Djibouti sucks my booty it was
like there's no it's just no it was
you're dealing with the I guess you're
at the whim of a warlord ready to be
running that area fiefdom yeah yeah I
mean like jail sucks in general right
like you don't want to Djibouti
that's that sucks your booty you really
do not want to spend a night at the
Graybar Hilton there you know but uh so
so anyways they're headed with the
Nigerian I was able to yeah because they
assumed that I was one of the one of the
white guys I was dressed like and all
those guys that you were with who were
fighting booked are on the Goodluck
Jonathan that the African Defense Force
they're all white actually they were
mixed they were mixed there is about you
know forty white guys there's about a
hundred and twenty of us total I think
it was about like forty white guys and
about eighty you know okay eighty black
guys but they were South African black
guys not Nigerian very different it was
also interesting for me to watch those
those old Afrikaans guys and like
culturally how they would interact like
other Dutch yeah exactly
very different yeah and the hierarchy is
alive and kicking like apartheid might
be over but like not in mics of those
guys right it was it was fascinating to
watch gonna be the next I really wonder
about South Africa I don't know how I
will you've got Julius Malema at the e
FF who's saying we're gonna take all the
land a land without appropriate without
compensation so all the white so why
like ten percent of the population which
is why owns eighty or ninety percent of
the land that's not gonna be sustainable
and you got these literal communists
actual Maoists yep who are like we're
gonna we're gonna take all the land that
works so well in Venezuela and and it's
worked so well in every other country
let's see what happens and Julius Malema
was the head who's a communications
major and his dumb and he's either he's
a he's a good statesman and speaker but
a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] about that just
has no experience in the in the world
and they and she is totally [ __ ] up
well that is so hot
Nancy is like a but we won't get into
that but that's a whole different thing
but but so so so I'm with all these
dudes and
sidebar like a bunch of those dudes got
killed like the first run I went out on
like we had a blue on blue with a
Nigerian unit and Nigerian tank opened
fire on our convoy with the with the
white killed two of the white guys like
just the shell or just ripped through
our convoy or we were just picking up
pieces of them so wait this is like as
in harm's way as so they they mistook
you guys for the enemy or what I mean
this was the Nigerian Army that fired
upon yeah I like it's like classic yeah
yeah one thing that has been so it was
so interesting about going there to
embed with those guys is that the battle
space and the way we conduct warfare for
us from the US Special Operations
community has evolved so much in the
last two decades of war like say what
you want like we have sharpened the
knife oh yeah right and the way we do it
with like air assets overhead the way
the battlespace has evolved the way the
comms architecture has evolved is
extraordinary it is it is so I don't
want to be a terrorist with an ak-47 you
know fighting the JSOC yeah because the
classic paradigm of asymmetric warfare
like doesn't work anymore because we're
practicing asymmetric warfare at scale
in this like orgy esque dance of
violence almost like you know we you
have we have a Italians like an Italian
JTAC with a you know a NATO like c2
platform overhead communicate came out
in communications platform overhead with
a predator drone like being flown by a
guy at Fallon Nevada right you got like
a Polish Grom guys or a Marine Corps QRF
quick reaction force in the background
in my platoon
you know I'd be having in one year I'd
be talking to like an Italian forward
air controller and then the guys in the
other ear right so it's like a
multi-national
complicated killing machine coming to
bear on the enemy like you can't imagine
the sophistication that's happened
over the last two decades and you're in
a it's animation you're in a ragtag
formation with and Here I am with a
bunch of like bush fighters who like
this is how they fought like warfare
jungle warfare 30 years again Bush Bob
where exactly yeah exactly and so like
you know no knock on them all of those
guys were hard but it was a different
style of warfare it was an old-school
style of warfare and you know for for me
even from him as an officer as a seal
officer from a mission planning
perspective we had were supposed to go
out and we had like a link-up time but
there was no like secondary tertiary
comms options and of course we were late
because you know no battle plan survives
the first shot so we were late for the
link-up with the Nigerians there's no
deconfliction Friend or Foe all of like
these procedures that we've honed over
the last sometime it's nervous and opens
up with a tank and just starts launch
firing on us firing on us right and so
she's the round comes in rips through
one of the vehicles that we had kills
two of the contractors and then look the
flipside of that is that like war is
still about like individual courage and
bravery and from there I saw the bravest
thing I've ever seen in my life which is
one of the guys running out of the
convoy and towards the Nigerian tank
jumping on the front of it
slapping it down and screaming like stop
[ __ ] firing right like that's that's
that's where you want that old-school
yeah break glass in case of war kind of
guy yeah well I mean I did the African
like those Dutch dudes like I we were on
Safari and and this is in this is in
celery and it's early in the morning and
my brother-in-law is a big strong swede
pro athlete like I'm not I'm not a [ __ ]
at all
my dad ex-marine big guy and and then of
course myself the the basically the man
girl and and everybody and the other
people dude we were I was wearing my dad
was wearing a down jacket I was wearing
like three layers and I was cold and I
hit I took one of the blankets and put
it on my legs because it in the morning
in Africa it's cold a [ __ ] right
I'm not we're and were driving in a be
cheap the dude the African guy the giant
Dutchman there the Samoans of Europe
they're [ __ ] huge he's in shorts and
a t-shirt and flip-flops and I one point
I looked at my father go how was this
guy not called how was not cold I said
my brother I was from Sweden who can
deal with the call I go he's not cold he
goes he they were just shaking their
head I go why are you not cold and he
goes because it's not cold yeah that's
that's why right because it's not cold
cuz it's not that was it like there
there are rough
that's cab boys these dudes and you know
say what you want and also remember like
some of these guys are like 50 oh yeah
50 plus years old and they are out there
in Borno State in madhu Guri
let me live going after Boko Haram
probably live for it you want you that
close the flame you know you you I'm
sure you have some of that you know
there's there's it there's that I mean
come on it's hard to when you're living
a civilian life and you're getting your
coffee from a dude with a nose ring and
everything is so safe after you've lived
that close to the flame it's must be
very difficult because everything else
is boring right well it's not just that
I mean I think you can stand up comic
yeah I don't know I think we run into
this [ __ ] just by a big virtue of being
here in this town yeah all the time I
remember what I've ever liked yeah when
I first arrived here yeah I was still
driving my 97 4runner which is like the
first car I had in the team's like great
cars still have it right it's my surf
car throw my boards in the back and I
pulled up like on a date to meet a girl
at Chateau Marmont and like the valet
gave me like so much [ __ ] like basically
wouldn't take my car or even talked to
me I didn't know anything no like the
Maury nothing nothing and i visible i
was like [ __ ] i have killed
better men than you so yeah what do you
need a guy like me to be like hey listen
let me explain to you okay so so so so
now you're so okay so now you have this
encounter with with the nigerian army
let's keep going yeah so basically that
got me to the that got me the front line
so nigerian army thought i was one of
the mercenaries and they were very
deferential to them
allowed me to bump to the front lines
and spend a bunch of time couple weeks
on the very front lines where they were
like trading shots literal of trench
warfare training shots back and forth so
that's how I covered one side of the
conflict the kinetic military side but
then as a journalist and a filmmaker
storyteller policy guy it was important
for me to see the other side so I did
what what we as journalists leaned
heavily on which is we use a network of
local fixers and connections that I had
made on the ground to help me organize
and arrange a meeting with some of the
Boko Haram commanders I did that the
negotiations were tense we the
negotiations were tense both with Boko
Haram how we were gonna meet in a
neutral location that was safe for them
and safe for me they're also tense
frankly with HBO and with Vice and with
the networks because we were way out in
unchartered waters here yeah yeah and
credit to those guys to the executives
at vice and each other at the end of the
day they were willing the argument that
convinced them wasn't that like hey I
can handle this I got a handshake deal
with the embassy for a bunch of Marines
on standby because there was like a
frogman working in the State Department
at the embassy so like I had some
friends but I was still pretty far out
there on my own
the but none of those arguments
convinced the executives at HBO what
convinced the executives at HBO to allow
me to go meet with a Boko Haram
commander secretly was that this is
important for the world and the risk was
worth the reward to hear a perspective
for them that nobody had ever seen good
for them and their right and their right
because nobody ever done that right and
so and I would imagine if they had found
out that you had been ex-military you
could have been in danger yeah possibly
I mean or not we or everybody use a
pretty trusted source we use a pretty
trusted source this woman yeah I was
sort of a little bit relying on the fact
that what I'm even if you're going there
with a camera
yeah and that we we use this woman who's
often affectionately know
mama Boko Haram to kind of negotiate and
broker the meeting I mean without
getting anybody in trouble if I were CIA
I would want I mean that's exactly how I
would pose so I could get in from Intel
on Boko Haram have an agency just pays
people it is simple yeah everybody
thinks intelligence work is this grad C
we're gonna do with a small camera yeah
yeah this is the guy yeah no you know
like my joke about case officers is like
they they need big biceps because they
got to carry all those bags of cash
around yeah that makes sense
so so how long were you with the agency
so total I went back and forth a couple
times but total I was boots on the
ground I think close to two or three
months Jesus yeah which again credit
that's that's a hard thing to do in this
like vicious fast news cycle where
people don't pay attention to Africa and
care about Africa to allow a
correspondent to go downrange and spend
that much time working on did you find
that like everything else they were
people and that they were probably
fighting was that really hot Jim do we
have to visually describe this she's
good that's it that's a different
conflict
her name's Claire ward she was one of my
cinematographers at Vice extraordinary
looking super yes she's very beautiful
and she is also an awesome journalist
what a badass she's a super badass
what up bring her up I need more
pictures of her play with it and she's
actually living in East Africa right now
she's about to have her her second baby
but she's a she's amazing journalist
when we were in Peru that was a story on
narco trafficking I mean seriously she
almost got her what the [ __ ] going on
keep going right what a badass i I mean
I I hate to take out this is why I don't
work with her overseas anywhere cuz
nobody pays attention to me but but I
mean good good on her man I love
somebody who's just a badass like that
Claire's awesome super smart great
journalist Canadian yeah fearless like
obviously fearless obviously that's the
thing about doing what you did I mean
that's
that is a ballsy thing to do because it
can go wrong in a heartbeat and you were
there for three months what did you what
did you glean from that whole conflict
what did you come away with sad super
sad I mean the some of those stories are
horrific gut-wrenching you know I feel I
like oh I'm part Nigerian now and like
here in the States no nobody knows me
but that video those documentaries went
crazy viral because even in the south
people are deathly afraid like no people
are like oh my god you've been with
tambour no like yeah like I would never
go there those guys are crazy they're so
scared so like I'm a big deal in Nigeria
all right everybody can recognize me
because they showed them a war that even
Nigerians hadn't seen and so but so I
feel very attached to Nigeria as a as a
country even you know the current
elections that are going on I follow
very closely
you know rooting for the people of
course of course and some of those
stories in the vice documentary for HBO
I interview this this woman named Zainab
who was 16 years old captured by Boko
Haram impregnated by a Boko Haram
fighter eventually returned to her
village and was encouraged by all of the
villagers to have an abortion right and
she refused to because they didn't want
to Boko Haram baby
Boko baby in their village but she said
no no no if I do that like then I'm just
like those guys Yeah right and so
imagine the courage and the will of a 16
year old girl who's been raped and
impregnated and kidnapped right to stand
up to the social and cultural pressure
of her village you could handle that you
can handle anything that's real strength
like people like that I'm amazed that's
real do you live in a country where
everybody's sensibilities and feelings
are so important they don't know what
the [ __ ] they're taught none of them
have been through anything and in a lot
of ways this is what Jonathan hi writes
about in the coddling of the American
mind these college students you have no
idea what the [ __ ] you like like when it
comes to adversity there are people out
there having grown up overseas I know
the
inherently having grown up in Pakistan
and India and Lebanon in the Middle East
III I saw it I traveled to Africa I
traveled to communist China I traveled
to communist Russia I saw it I saw how a
lot of people lived and I saw how people
didn't have anything and and so your
feelings and your humaneness in essence
it's not important you know there's a
fundamental division Americans a lot of
times especially privileged Americans
like the ones we find in our colleges
and everybody else is that everybody
else is basically look I'm a tiny leaf
on a huge tree and Americans are brought
up to believe that we are the tree and
that is a fundamental difference well
this is
you know you and I have discussed quite
a bit offline you know how difficult is
sometimes to transition back from from
military service or from overseas but I
also believe that it's possible to gain
incredible perspective from those
experiences overseas and from combat
experiences and look I think I grew from
my compassion not only more
compassionately more grateful and like
you know there's it's not a movie right
it's not a like a hallmark movie with a
perfect score where you come back and
you have this grand Epiphany but in
general I think what it does is it
brings life into more clear focus and
makes you appreciate like all that good
stuff so you know every day I'm alive is
in the black hooray and so if I'm off
you know spearfishing or scuba diving or
free diving or whatever or having a good
meal down there on Abbot Kinney I think
it's so just like a touch sweeter
because our perspective of having been
overseas I can't even I was never in the
military but I did I went to Afghanistan
I did stand up for the guys for two
weeks in 2008 I think and I went through
the hospital and I saw a little boy who
had lost his legs in a landline and then
we saw some other stuff and and then we
had four pine boxes loaded at our feet
in Kandahar and they were 19-year old
Marines who had been killed in a suicide
bombing then we saw a [ __ ] sort of a
ceremony for our some of the Fallen guys
and try keeping a dry eye by the way
Mikey I'm not comfortable with emotions
but I was crying behind my [ __ ]
sunglasses like you know
and I came back after this insane
experience which was just a great honor
for me to do and I I was in a restaurant
on Abbot Kinney and I ordered the lamb
and the guy came over and apologized
profusely because they'd run out of lamb
and I know this was a huge inconvenience
for me I know the 11 year old our 4 year
old or whatever it was because he was
dude they don't have good nutrition lost
his legs but they didn't have my [ __ ]
lamb so I was so I had the guy fired
obviously yeah and I was screaming why
me why me and I stormed out and and and
and I I'll never go back to that
restaurant again no but it just puts
everything in perspective
it I mean look as a kid though I always
talked about this you know I saw what
what advanced stage leprosy does to
somebody's face I saw all that [ __ ] as a
kid I saw what it was like to have
groups of children come up and beg at
your window and I was behind I was in an
air-conditioned car that [ __ ] changes
you it fills you full of shame it makes
you kind of go why did I get lucky the
[ __ ] am i lucky for you know and I and I
know you've seen that and way more and
especially in 2000 in the 2000s which is
kind of crazy but it still exists right
yeah and I mean that you know whatever
if I have like a positive kind of like
generally buoyant disposition it's
because of exactly what you just
described like I at least like have
gained the perspective that I have been
on the the privileged end of the
spectrum and there's nothing like being
overseas yeah kind of remember that and
this is not like about wrapping yourself
in the flag or anything like that like
it has nothing to do with it like you
see like you said a little Afghan boy
and like who's stepped on a landmine
and what his life is it's also true in
Cambodia I was did another piece for
vice HBO about landmines in in Burma and
size with the Burmese rebel so like the
explosive remnants of war exist ever
globally everywhere you also did
something on extraordinary rendition I
did can you explain that because I've
always been fascinated with it because
let me let me give you my definition of
extraordinary rendition and then you can
tell me if I'm correct yeah because I
couldn't quite believe it
I believe that extraordinary rendition
is when the CIA realizes that there is a
high-value target let's just say a
terrorist who's responsible for killing
Americans or whatever and we with the
help or not the help of the local
authorities in that country come in grab
that guy throw a hood over his head
put him in an unmarked plane and fly him
to a country where the torture laws are
kind of loose like Poland or wherever it
might be you know they're allies so if
he accidentally gets electrodes put to
his nuts well we didn't do it they're
their people did it or let's just say
there are a lot of Arab countries that
don't have strict rules on torture or
interrogation techniques so am i right
about that
yeah I mean look one that was like 95%
like a perfect explicit description of
what it is in terms of there's there's a
small but important distinction and what
you said is use Poland as like a kind of
off-the-cuff example what happened in
the Eastern European countries is a
different type of rendition than the
classic rendition which you're
describing which is a better more
precise example might be say fly someone
off to Egypt and let the state security
forces interrogate them and there are
humane Bono taking out the mic okay the
right so that um so prior to 9/11 and
even post 9/11 that kind of
extraordinary rendition was the kind of
rendition that was the most commonplace
what happened post 9/11 which has been
much revealed now is that the CIA set up
a series of secret black sites around
the world in places like Thailand and
Poland and Romania and these the
distinction there is that these were
prisons run by the CIA and the
interrogation programs known as the RDI
program the rendition and detention
interrogation program has the word
rendition in it but they were
auditioning them to their own facilities
as black sites co-located in foreign
countries but not with the cooperation
so you have you
might wanna you'd rather be maybe with
the CIA than in an Egyptian yeah I mean
because at least with the CIA there are
rules the extraordinary rendition
practice that you've described his
mostly stopped right and according to
federal zone American right that called
being on American clapping so so that
that really doesn't happen what happened
post 9/11 is that they they brought all
of that detention and interrogation
in-house and that was new territory for
the agency and they stood up this
program and well they didn't have that
much experience did they I mean no and
this was the problem so they're starting
from scratch they hired two CIA
contractors they're paid close to eighty
million dollars to design and implement
the rendition detention interrogation
program occurred in all these different
spots around the world the Senate got
wind of it there was this long Senate
report that didn't name the contractors
use pseudonyms to name them but
described the entire Pro contractors as
an individuals or contractors as in
companies it was one company but it was
basically two former Air Force
psychologists right who designed the
program now nobody really knew who these
guys were but I knew who they were and
so I revealed one of them to the world
for the first time for a vice
documentary in this in this micro doc
called the architect because he was the
architect of the program and I did it in
kind of like a bizarre weird way he
lives down in in Tampa where Special
Operations Command is so I went to visit
my buddy Jim down in Tampa and I
interviewed him on a canoe in a lake
surrounded by thousands of alligators
here because I thought it was a good
metaphor for how he sees the world it's
so bizarre and so surreal so here's Jim
and Jim Jim personally waterboarded
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed 183 times so not
only did he design the program in 83
time not only did he design the program
not only did he profit from it he also
implemented it and I don't mean any of
this Jim is a complicated character and
I consider him
a friend a real friend well I I'm not
what would happen see when we were in
new territory right and everybody was
terrified and the CIA was the one I
always say this like when the towers
come down or a bomb explodes or a
hundred thousand Europeans or Americans
or whoever are killed or two hundred
thousand or whatever is possible with
technology what all of us do is we go
the battle we got to get the bad guys
and we we always know that we have guys
who can do that guys and gals but
probably a lot of guys we know that well
we all go where where's Delta where's
where's devgru where where those guys
we're seeing all of us do that we don't
know how it works it's almost like when
you get cancer I mean are you going to a
good doctor good that there's a
specialist go they go there they'll save
your life we don't know how it happens
but we know that they're there we have
those men and women in white coats it's
the same idea so that job when you are
improvising at the speed of life and
people are dying and a lot of people
could die and your margin for error is
basically no you can't [ __ ] up your your
your gonna do [ __ ] that's you're gonna
and by the way Oh invent a way to
interrogate okay here's 80 million
dollars this is all this is all
fly-by-night [ __ ] so it's the I own I do
have forgive and understand the idea
that there's a great deal of error
that's gonna happen along the way as we
learn this stuff totally and for these
guys they were flying the airplane right
while they built it right they were
figuring it out in real time and look
that doesn't excuse for me I very rarely
like place any blame at the feet of the
individual operator on the ground right
it's a combina
as leaders and as policy makers to put
safeguards on these kind of things but
also to learn from the past and also to
learn I have learned a lot from from the
Iraq invasion which I was semi approving
of because I was like the it's it's
there'd be a lot of incentive for a
state with that much money and that much
military expertise and will to
accidentally on purpose drop a nuclear
weapon or weapon of mass destruction in
someone's hands Alkaid his hands or
whatever I understood that I understood
that like making an example of a
government but then of course I was
wrong in a lot of ways too because I
didn't you know a lot of my friends who
were liberal quote-unquote and kind of
left-wing and we're really against it I
was critical of but I think they were
right I think and it's okay I mean I
I've been wrong a lot in my life but but
but I do think it's very important that
we learn that we really learn from these
lessons as opposed to what I think is
really going on is that what we are
learning also is that there's a lot of
money in conflict in war and let's just
you know let's just keep it going man
and by the way there are a lot of
governments that want to stay in power
like Saudi Arabia and stuff and they
have to kill a journalist or maybe a lot
of political enemies let's get some
ex-seal guys to do it we'll pay you a
shitload of money man hey you're killing
terrorists yeah and look I think these
are the most important and the most
interesting questions of the last two
decades this is where I've spent the
body of my civilian work is in asking
these questions my history with the the
enhanced interrogation program which was
effectively created by Jim Mitchell who
I just talked about it down in Florida
of the hit my history with that is I was
the first person to be waterboarded on
national TV it was like the assignment
it was when I was trying to pay for
Harvard and I was working at Al Gore's
television network Current TV my first
TV network and I had this harebrained
idea everybody was talking about
waterboarding and it was a debate within
the annals of national security you saw
people opining about is it torture is it
not torture that whole thing john mccain
went to war with the White House over
this issue right and everybody's talking
about it like nobody knew what it was so
I was like well I know what it was yeah
I know what it is I just have to get
word of order don't you sometimes I got
waterboarded in in sere school yeah my
son he was like it's torture he's a
tough [ __ ] and he goes to me and I was
torture you know it like I told you like
my experience that the first go-around
know is you know they they strap me to
that board and you have this like
backstory cover story that you're
supposed to kind of resist them
extracting information the whole school
is designed to teach you to resist and
tarah Gatien right you go you go there
right and then so anyways they strap me
down to that water board and they
started you putting the hose in my mouth
or whatever and then they like so
they're find out what it is yeah so
waterboarding is a torture I'm sorry
Anantara
it's an interrogation technique dating
back to King Ferdinand and Queen
Isabella when they tried to rid the
Spanish the peninsula of Moors and Jews
and other undesirables so it comes out
of Middle Ages right right so it's
really an interrogation technique using
water and simulating drowning that dates
back hundreds of years and history is
fascinating like the Nazis used it in
World War two we we court-martialed
Americans for using it in the Vietnam I
want to watch this by the way we have
this yes a video actually oh that's it
that's it yeah yeah there's there's me
second water so go on so waterboarding
is this is this create is this this
technique that's gone for a long time
it's most modern incarnation was
probably done by the Khmer Rouge during
the Cambodian genocide and in fact I got
the idea for the story when I was on
that Spring Break assignment on land
mines and I was at toll slang which is a
museum where the Khmer Rouge killed
20,000 Cambodians and I saw a picture of
waterboarding on the wall and I saw this
through line between all these nefarious
regimes who had waterboarded and then
that we were waterboarding right so I go
I pay this dude a thousand bucks to have
myself waterboarded he was a former sere
instructor and we film it in the this
basement in Rhode Island because it was
the closest place to Boston where I was
living at the time and and we put it up
and it goes it goes like pretty pretty
crazy because nobody had ever seen it
although funny little backstory which I
think you'll appreciate I submitted it
to the network and then it goes into as
you know the video then goes into
post-production or whatever in like two
weeks later they call me and they're
like hey cause we we can't find the
footage to go into edit of the
waterboarding and I was like oh I am NOT
doing that [ __ ] again what do you mean
you can't provide the footage like it
turns out to underscore that nobody
really knew what it was
the guy who ingests the footage yeah had
seen the title waterboarding and he
thought it was a new extreme sport like
wakeboarding or something so he had
filed it after all the sports footage oh
[ __ ] yeah and it was missing for like
two weeks and the piece my most famous
piece that was the first time I was on
national TV and all this stuff almost
didn't happen God does that that's watch
this let's watch this oh he's a you yeah
what does that know so part of the thing
is they have to stuff a rag or a piece
of parachute cloth that's the most
effective way in your mouth that keeps
you from spitting the water back up as
any and now as you're having water push
down here your nose yeah so they they're
they're holding my mouth so that I don't
you know miss the stream it's more
effective with a hose although or a
bucket although it's equally effective
through your hearing you can't breathe
right now
can't breathe yeah and you'll see it
starts to get you can tolerate it for a
little bit but you'll see me start to
shake after a while that's not good
yeah that's horrible what we do to other
human beings yeah and I was at the time
keenly aware of the fact that my buddies
were still downrange and overseas and
they in all likelihood could be captured
and it's possible that the only thing
that prevented them from being subjected
to torture was the fact that we had
always held this very strong moral line
torture a hundred percent it's so
important so that's where I ultimately
fell in the equation saying the moral
high ground that's how it was actually
my Professor Alan Dershowitz I
interviewed him about it that was your
professor yeah doing it the way we do it
without accountability and deniability
so this actually goes on for I like
tercer woods I think he's right there's
just a straight shooter he's complicated
guy but he's always been super willing
to engage on these issues whenever he's
not he's he's like if we have to do it
fine but have transparency that is what
says you know we wouldn't really need
torture like if there's a guy who knows
where Obama's
then then okay but just just who's doing
it and just know that we're doing it
yeah his his position is nuanced he says
that the the very least if we're gonna
engage in this behavior we have to be
completely transparent about it I I
think yes so the this really kicked off
my long history of that last that looks
awful I could 23 minutes dude oh you
were waterboard for 23 minutes yeah cuz
[ __ ] them how did you feel after that
yeah I was all right like I recovered
like it wasn't as bad as the first time
but it was it was bad 23 5 minutes yeah
well I kind of messed it up like
honestly like I should have had a safe
word or something but I didn't have like
a good plan going in because I wanted it
to be as authentic and realistic as
possible you can never simulate actually
being captured obviously but I wanted it
to be close yeah yeah so that people
could at least have an informed debate
about what we should be doing yeah I
mean listen that that's that's very
powerful looking at that I looking at
that well you're tied up and you're I
mean that [ __ ] is to me is it torture or
is it interrogation it's torture
yeah it's torture yeah it's even by I'm
not a lawyer but like I had to dig deep
enough into the legal infrastructure
surrounding this never for both this
film for the architect film and
eventually for a scripted feature that
was just made and inspired by all this
stuff and the legal definition of
torture is essentially pain equivalent
to death which is obviously very
subjective but this is this is pretty
damn close you do think you're gonna die
yeah I kind of feel like the
psychologists and the lawyers who are
okaying this should be waterboarded so
that they have an idea of what they're
okay not because they're bad people but
it might be nice to know a little bit
about what your what you're actually
saying is legal just just to stay super
honest all of us yeah and you know
that's a gray area but it look at this
these are these are tough questions yeah
is it even possible to conduct ethical
warfare that's a real question my mom
would say no that's a
great question right my mom would say no
she doesn't believe in it she doesn't
believe in violence of any conscience
she doesn't think it's possible so here
I am Zi do me too
well that's a schism was stopped by I
mean six million Jews were slaughtered
and what stopped those guys was violence
was overwhelming violence what
essentially eradicated slavery in our
country and actually the world in many
cases was violence was a war so we can
go on and on about about that and you
know I think communism in its in the way
in its forms was a very evil thing and I
think a market economy is better for
people and I think a lot of times that
war was won with guns I hate to say that
know that first of all I'm gonna recruit
you to the next family Thanksgiving
cause like I need more allies in this
fight but this is what I tell my mom who
I love very dearly and I'm very close
with right my mom is a true pacifist God
says Mahatma Gandhi style pacifist who
does not believe in this but what I
would say at our our family discourse
our family debates which we're still
very loving is that I like you
I believe that force is sometimes
required to do good in the world
and I could cite you a bunch of examples
of why but you just you just we know we
know that when bad men what would we
know that whoever has a monopoly on
violence which is usually a central
government but we know that if that
government is not for the people by the
people and other people we know what
happens and those people in power will
kill you they'll kill your kids they'll
do whatever look all of us passivist you
want to be a pacifist awesome the Nazis
would've shot Gandhi and I really do
respect passive resistance I've read
Thoreau on civil disobedience blob of I
get it but we all know that at the end
of the day if you don't have men with
guns guarding those walls I mean I'll
just how how did how would the pass
misses down against the Mongols oh yeah
they killed everybody anyway it doesn't
matter so I wonder would Isis be I guess
you could convert to Islam but you
better do what they say
look I mean the bottom line is it's not
realistic and you're right there is a
time and a place for for violence there
just is and like you I I got no problem
going downrange and killing Isis guys
but I will say like as I scale back the
the polygon like me you've done it the
policy guy in me also says that's what
economists would call necessary but not
sufficient I also recognize that we need
a whole host of other tools and elements
of national power in order to really
solve that's why you have rule of law so
it's not a well gonna need a convention
it's a part of it rule of law Geneva
Conventions cruel a bans against cruel
and unusual punishment courts that can
these are so important that's why you
you have to have a military government
must be account held accountable by a
civilian government I couldn't be a
bigger proponent of that anybody who
thinks that warriors or a military all
due respect to the military should run a
country you're out of your [ __ ] mind
that's not what this country was founded
on for a very good reason if you think
that you should pick up a history book
cuz you're you're not an educated human
being you're actually destructive the
founding fathers this country is a great
country because we have and by the way
you can even make an argument that this
could this we've got the baddest
military on the planet because they're
beholden to a military to a civilian
government in a lot of ways
yeah it's inconvenient yeah sometimes
the generals get pissed off yeah
sometimes we don't fight a great war
like in Vietnam because it's things
getting away still a great idea hundred
percent and uh I'll take it one step
further in my first Platoon you know I
was a junior officer and I was an
officer in charge and we had like a
little platoon Hut structure my unit I
used to have this this phrase written on
the wall that and the Thucydides phrase
that I'm sure you've heard before which
is that any nation that draws to great
it divided between its warriors and its
scholars will have its fighting done by
fools and it's thinking done by cowards
yeah that's great so never heard that
yeah it's amazing I used to have it up
in the platoon space Wow because like I
say it again so people can hear it I
love you
so I'm bastardize it at least this time
around like any nation that draws two
graded divided between its warriors and
its scholars will have its fighting done
by fools and its thinking done by
cowards so good it's so good so I for
myself in my own life have always tried
to embrace this this duality and this
this idea of being a Renaissance man
that I can be both a fighter and a
thinker that I can be both a warrior and
a scholar and I think honestly part of
the reason you and I bonded to each
other at that dinner it's like there's
the initial kind of like
knuckle-dragging part work like me I
think you cut my face it all started
from bugs yeah you can walk into any
other and be like this is from yeah yeah
like I was come from the gym this
morning right like I can we can both
walk into any room and be like okay
who's the dude in there that like if
things go really south right we're gonna
exfil together right who's that dude I
was like I think it's that - I think
it's that scrappy dude right there right
but and so we're like okay hey we should
talk because like you know if the zombie
apocalypse comes it's gonna be me and
you is it's very right I certainly feel
I would never call myself a tough guy
but I certainly feel very comfortable
around like I just have always been
drawn to those kind of guys I feel more
calm we both roll when we both box right
and we have that background and you can
just see in like somebody else's posture
okay you're like oh this is this is the
guy oh yeah but but that's like that's
not why we're friends nah we're friends
because we started talking and we
started debating ideas and who started
thinking about like these really
important macro issues exactly right so
that's what that's sustainable yeah
we're actually having real conversations
about things that matter yeah yeah I was
I was really psyched to have you at that
dinner because I'll sit next to this
[ __ ] great so so you do this thing
called the architect mm-hmm and it's
about extraordinary renditions yeah and
you come out you you expose one of the
guys who's one of the psychologists
which i think is great for the world now
what is the conclusion I mean the
conclusion is that that was a pretty
dark chapter in American history
and it's important get information we
needed though well sort of in the in the
Dershowitz with I'll get to my opinion
on it in a second but like sort of in
the the Dershowitz principle like hey if
we're gonna engage in these behaviors
and policies let's be really transparent
and let's have a robust public debate
about it and let's have an informed
public debate about it yeah so that
that's the conclusion like look I do
think not everything mostly I believe
that sunshine is the the best
disinfectant right but I also come from
the silent professional world and I
understand that some things have to be
done in the annals of national security
and that's where why good right but we
need good leadership and good safeguards
there for it and so I think the
conclusion of the architect is that we
have to be incredibly thoughtful when we
come close to those kind of red lines
and we have to ask ourselves what are
what are our very core and prime values
right and I think the ultimate answer
for like did it work
like did we get bin Laden because we
tortured KSM and he and he blinked when
we mentioned the courier's name you know
look I I don't really know what I would
argue is that I don't think it matters
that probably the moral cost is greater
than any small intelligence gain the the
recruiting capability is the the erosion
of our moral standing in the world when
there's even the perception that we
would engage in things that could be
perceived as torture are not worth the
intelligence value I think that was
whatever weekend I think that was been a
lot of the biggest victory totally I
really do I think his biggest victory
was the ability to to compromise our
credibility our moral standing in the
world but or to engage us in two decades
of perpetual 100 percent right like and
you know for me I always say this thing
that you know Warriors are the most
reluctant
to go to war because we say no effects
of it like I heard that I remember in
2003 when it was being debated it was
the soldiers
it was Powell it was the guys who who
had who were in uniform who are like hey
you guys really want to slip and let
slip the dogs of war you really want to
do this because if you guys want to do
this it's gonna get you you that's what
I always say about people who talk
loosely about violence right I mean the
Mafia understood this they call it the
unintended consequences of killing right
a hundred percent you should have just
just having some combat experience just
getting punched in the face punching
somebody else in the face with bad
intention just that alone forget taking
a gun and being able to look at some of
these eyes and shoot them in the face
that's a whole different thing but you
know and until you in warriors have done
a lot of that and they've seen also the
the sort of ramifications of that like
you said that sort of that the
shockwaves of you know killing somebody
and hearing their wife scream whatever
it might be though that's the kind of
[ __ ] that a lot of these guys and
especially operators deal with it's very
[ __ ] difficult for them because
because war makes a mockery some someone
so often of all these linear concepts
like duty loyalty and honor a hundred
percent right a hundred percent in it
and it twists and turns them in in ways
that you can't even process like look I
could give you a long policy
dissertation on the last two decades of
war and the the current state of talks
with the Taliban and Afghanistan right
and what's happening in Syria but like
here's the here's the bottom bottom
[ __ ] line is that I was in buds on
9/11 I was a wartime seal and my almost
entire military service with the
exception of the Naval Academy component
you know has been a nation at war and
I'm just [ __ ] tired right
like I've carried I've so many boxes
like so many of my friends funerals I
even this right this is my friend Jonas
Kelso who was killed in the extortion 17
mission we were really good friends in
the SEAL Teams and that was when the
helicopter went down that was August 6
2011 yeah exactly I was supposed to be I
think Andy Stumpf was that was his uh I
think that I think it was his troop and
then he
he got shot in the ass exactly I was
this true exactly exactly and you know
Andy and I obviously went to high school
to get some long deep conversations that
guy he's just a great he's extraordinary
yeah he's really extraordinary yeah yeah
it's really funny to think about you
know we started off like running against
each other as junior lifeguards in the
sand in Santa Cruz yeah they're built
kind of similar yeah I could just see
the competition
yeah then we ended up you know the the
sands the Coronado you know and stuff
together but um yeah so okay you know I
don't have it all figured out but like
I'm like anybody else I'm just I'm just
trying to process what it means to have
been part of the two longest wars in
American history you now have a TV show
you sold we can't talk about who the
network is but but this is a show you
you that's gonna come out tell me about
it
yeah it's a TV series so you know it's
kind of an extension of my work at vice
where the way he'll he'll he'll be a
Navy SEAL for 14 years he'll then go to
Harvard then there'll be a war
correspondent you [ __ ] failure all
right killin bet himself with Boko Haram
and a bunch of other [ __ ] and then he'll
expose the extraordinary rendition and
then if he wants he'll sell a TV show
keep going Kosh by the way what kind of
name is Kosh I love it
what's my hippie parents do Kaja larson
with hippie parents - all right keep
going blue eyes the real Bradley Cooper
you're not quite as cute but you're all
right uh-uh
it's the truth hurts I know man I'm like
I'm like a shark I got to keep swimming
in her I die I hear that I hear that
you're talking about hustler I believe
for a living and you do something else
but you know yes sir go on yeah so so
when I I left Vice I started producing
some independent productions and I have
a bunch of projects including this
docu-series that I just sold which is
about narco trafficking so one of the
things I covered extensively advise
including that picture you pulled up
earlier with with Claire
are the drug wars in Central and South
America dude so we gotta get into this I
do oh this oh yeah dude I spent a lot of
time in like Culiacan which is the
capital of Sinaloa which is headquarters
of the Sinaloa Federation [ __ ]
largest drug cartel in the world what
yeah yeah I made in that Peruvian
documentary there I made cocaine in a
clandestine lab in Lima oh yeah looks
that up I looked up what it takes to
make cocaine that's a multi-tiered
process took all night oh yeah the guy
who was cooking it like the the Cucina
like the the cook guy in the kitchen
said like if people knew how I made
cocaine they would never
okay yeah so so you because I always I
want to hear all about this guy I wrote
this joke about how people like only
drink single sourced coffee you know
because they want to respect the farmer
yeah and I'm like I only do locally
sourced cocaine because there's so much
murderer they don't have a labor union
yeah a lot of blood in that cookie it's
like a Blood Diamond like a blood so if
you don't blow a lot you know and you
really care about the world you might be
you might be the ultimate hypocrite I
don't know if I'm right about that but I
might be I just think I just think
there's a market for conflict free coke
yeah that's amazing
yeah yeah I gotta write that more but
but so so so please yeah please please
expand so so I've covered this lot I
covered it at at CNN in a little micro
talk series called narco Wars I I
covered it extensively advice and I've
followed the drug trade for a long time
and it's been on my radar in uniform
there's been different times that I've
deployed to in the sock south which is
Special Operations Command south which
is the area of operations that oversees
Latin in Central America so it's a it
used to be in the old days pre 9/11 like
a lot of the work of the SEAL Teams was
what we called CNT counter narco
trafficking and so a lot of the funding
lines for military operations were seedy
counter drug lines and stuff and so
while the war on terror
obviously loomed large and dominated the
majority of our time and attention and
resources over the last two decades
there have been different times where I
have been you know at different seal
units are at different briefings or
involved in some of the counter
narcotics work that the Millett that is
done on the DoD side and there's some
really interesting interagency stuff
that's happening between DoD and defense
yeah Department of Defense the Coast
Guard DEA I have a very close working
relationship with the DEA they were very
supportive of this last series that I
just did I was one the few d yes anybody
going to the DEA yeah and said hey dude
let's legalize drugs maybe that's the
best way to do this you know I gotta say
I want to hear your point of view I
here's what here's what I think about
the DEA guys just like small from a
small cultural perspective they're kind
of the last cowboy culture in law
enforcement I get along with these dudes
I was with him in Afghanistan I've been
with him in Honduras which at one point
was like the murder capital of the world
been with them in El Salvador been with
him in Mexico been with him here in the
States doing operations these are the
dudes in law enforcement that I get
along with that remind me of my SEAL
brethren more than any other dudes yeah
they're the last cowboy collaborative
matters they're real door kickers these
guys yeah they got it end they also do a
lot of stuff that they don't get credit
for right so they often white label
their bus they let the local guys take
the credit but it was really them and
that's to protect sources an informant I
heard that that's what Delta did or
someone did with Pablo Escobar like they
were like there he's over there you guys
take the credit we'll just disappear
yeah yeah I mean there's there's a lot
of that stuff that happens in in the
world and and that's okay I'm okay with
it like yeah there there's some there's
some things that just need to happen
outside of the public sphere but the
agency guys that the DEA guys are
fantastic that being said they are in
this kind of like rolling the boulder
uphill feudal battle and they know it
because these guys are think dumb
course there's supers fiscal it's just a
job for them yeah they have a job to do
I mean there's a lot of money in drug
prevention as well and or at least in
the illegal ization I mean you have a
whole do you have these giant government
agencies that all honorable people doing
the best job they can but the larger
question of course the macro question
becomes hey people are gonna get high we
know that no matter what people are
gonna get high so is there any value in
the idea of just make it legal grow it
here it's like how I feel about rhino
horn flood the market with fake rhino
horn and all the rhino horns we cut off
anyway flood the market just give it to
everybody and then just do big
documentaries on how it doesn't get your
dick hard it's just made it Karen send
that to China I swear to god people will
no longer be you can kill the market you
can kill it but they won't do that they
harvest the horn like get to [ __ ]
give put the one out there so the key
word is you nailed it and if I would sum
up you know having just done an entire
docu-series on this you know shot in 17
countries including Kenya and
Afghanistan and you know Central America
and Mexico or all the other bad spots in
the world is it's a market like this is
a market problem so my series looks at
the economic lens of narco trafficking
so we look at the Sinaloa Federation
which is the largest drug cartel in the
world and how they operate like Apple or
Walmart do they for sure explain that
okay so let's take a farm to arm bush to
Street kind of methodology with cocaine
that starts in Colombia the producers
have now outsourced distribution to the
Mexicans they add value to the supply
chain throughout the entire process they
have marketing arms even in like say a
place like Honduras or Salvador right
you know ms-13 so all of those all of
those gangs in Central and South America
are basically effectively organized
labor to move product right and like if
you think about a mess controlled by who
by the larger cartels now previously by
the Colombian cartels but when the
Colombia
cartels made the business decision to
outsource distribution to the Mexicans
they gave more power to the Mexican
cartels so they're now running you know
you got the Zetas running da see Ocho in
Honduras or in Salvador they were kind
of shut down right right and but their
sin Allah the problem is when you kill
these though when you capture or kill
these the leaders like El Chapo you
atomized it and it creates more of
violence because they start fighting
over turf don't they certainly I mean
that's certainly the argument that the
Mexican government has said is that for
many years they opted for a kind of
stability picking their cartels it was
always implied that the Sinaloa
Federation had the tacit support of the
PRI I'm excited but fully in support of
that now so to fit like to finish the
metaphor you know you got an ms-13 gang
banger who's running drugs for say
Sinaloa and he's got this massive face
tattoo like on his face right if you are
a drug cartel and you have organized
labor in the form of gangs you what
happens if the Zetas recruit one of your
dudes away like you can't take them to
court for predatory hiring practices
right you can only litigate in the
streets or you can slap a giant face
tattoo the ugliest face tattoo you've
ever seen like what is that in the
language of business
that's a non-compete clause right you
got a 13 on your forehead yeah you're
not going to work for Dec Ocho for 18 No
so all of this stuff that usually when
you think about it from from an economic
one's from a business when we use the
language of business the drug trade
reveals itself to be what it actually is
which is a commodities trade and in the
history of commodities trades where you
have demand we've never really been able
to effectively ban a commodities trade
well the only thing we've ever been able
to do is like legalize tax and regulate
accident yeah so the the macro come out
indicator is is like cotton man right
the kind of product exactly exactly so
you know that's after after studying
this for for so many years in so many
months
that's where the conclusion seems to
push towards and then there's just the
like holy [ __ ] we spend so many billions
of dollars right 60,000 people dead in
Mexico and and and what's happened to
the supply side of the curve just keeps
going up man of course it keeps going up
course and not you know we have a heroin
episode to like not to beat you down but
you know 72 thousand people you know are
gonna die of opioid overdoses this is
real people man that's right people's
children
there's Americans 17,000 American yes
72,000 Americans so if can you imagine
if so how many people were killed in
9/11 uh I think was at 3,000 almost yeah
this is 72,000 right it laughs it's a
joke compared to night attack it's like
it Dwarfs anything that's ever happened
was terrorist was exactly exactly so
what you know just like intuitively like
you don't got to be like a Harvard
policy nerd to feel like this [ __ ] isn't
working yeah and that we we got to find
an alternative everybody has to know
that I mean sort of
yeah but you know anyway yes yeah I feel
like okay we talked about torture we
talked about drugs love it we talked
about war and conflict yeah but it's a
really important cool [ __ ] you're fast
to hear tell your audience to like put
the razor blades away I feel bad this
like slit your wrists I think it's
really interesting because you're a guy
would spin at the tip of the spear
you've been involved you're there with
your feet dirty and hands dirty that's a
big deal and you and and did you get to
know any drug cartel people yeah yeah I
mean honestly making cocaine in that
clandestine lab in the slums of Lima
like I like those dudes like you know I
I got to know a lot of them at many
different stages of the process and you
know leave my a dangerous place for a
foreigner to go like myself no we missed
an awesome place foods great what about
what about meta-gene what Colombia has
become very safe right it used to be
that you couldn't drive from Bogota to
meta-gene right right now you can the
whole country especially mostly because
of the the peace process with the FARC
has made Colombia and not only like
Colombia is a gorgeous country and super
safe
but Mexico's very dangerous Mexico's
dangerous although I will say that
broadly speaking the drug violence has
been contained to people involved in the
trade
it hasn't really except for a very few
like small examples leaked out into say
the tourist industry or anybody can hear
about these stories like like where the
Zetas were killing bus loads of migrants
I mean in kids and stuff like what the
[ __ ] is that about yeah like what that
brutality it's definitely happened and
their control for the plaza or like a
particular territory for from
distributing and transporting drugs has
been vicious and brutal without a doubt
there's this whole thing about the the
lost women of Ciudad Juarez right like a
ton of women who have gone missing
really yeah and and you know the other
thing to understand about cartels
through the language of businesses that
like any good there multinational
corporations right like but they're not
singular and they're their product or
their organizational structure or their
the lawsuit sounds like the work of a
couple serial killers who are organized
that's what it sounds like I think the
leading theory has been that it's been
about human trafficking for the sex
industry both like across the border and
stuff there might also be that some
component but in general what it signals
is that the cartels have diversified as
well in their business model so they're
in everything yeah this narco gone rogue
guerrilla was it guerrilla yeah he's
great his stuffs great essential
research for a guy like me yeah yeah wow
talk about how they're into oil stealing
oil everything that's a big deal if
there's a lot of revenue coming that way
cuz they're spart they're smart
businessman they're smart businessman
yeah yeah yeah the question is it just
seems like as I get older
again another issue where you can't
shoot or bomb your way out of this
problem
you just can't well put ain't that crazy
and so are we evolving are we learning
and as we learn like where do we go from
here
yeah that's what fascinated me yeah yeah
well you're kind of at the you're kind
of at the forefront of this you're
bringing it to us I am like look
I don't know what I'm doing got this TV
show I know I got this TV show I mean
what I am doing is what I think when I
think about my generation of veterans
and I think about you know the world war
two generation of veterans which came
back from World War two and built this
country into the the greatest economic
engine the world has ever seen
right and we suffered we suffered we
were given so much prosperity because of
their their efforts and of that
generation the greatest generation and
then Vietnam happened and it was an
utter disaster reintegrating veterans
back into society there was a point I
did another doc about veterans in prison
and how they're showing up in higher
numbers now and but we should have known
all of this because you know post
Vietnam one in five incarcerated
Americans was a Vietnam veteran I don't
know there was a long precedent for this
and of course it makes sense because
they come back they're all [ __ ] up for
more right they like self-medicate like
all of this stuff their economic
opportunities aren't there especially
post Vietnam it was really bad and I
like to say that the the battle for this
generation of veterans is still up for
grabs
we could be considered like the
post-vietnam generation as this like
PTSD laid in you know generation that
comes back and ends up in prison and
like we're dealing with the opioid
crisis and like 22 suicides a day all of
that [ __ ] is real
brethren a lot of your JSOC guys tons
it's for taking most of the fighting
it's a huge issue and it's really real
but it's not the only model there's an
alternative model the alternative model
is guys coming back like that generation
from World War two and reintegrating
into society and continuing to add value
continuing to serve just at a uniform
and if my generation of veterans does
that effectively then we'll be like
those World War two guys we can then be
the next greatest generation of veterans
so when I think about what I'm doing
like I'm just trying to continue my
service and keep moving like the shark
keeps swimming like the shark and and
and do as much as possible to continue
to contribute that's that's [ __ ]
awesome
let's it's just so great and um did you
when you were doing this narco thing did
you you had cameras with a lot of you
were around yeah dudes who didn't want
to be seen
yeah that's the hard part about being a
TV journalist right like these print
guys like grello
I mean I'm joking like he's a great
great turtle it's like those dudes got
it so easy right like I gotta have like
a c300 on my shoulder right which means
like which basically says shoot me right
you want to hear so oh this is crazy
I'll appreciate this as a media guy you
want to know like one one of the dumbest
things I've ever seen in media is are
you familiar with the red camera like
the red epics and all that stuff have
you seen what they like label all those
like there were loading themes they all
say like bomb like the red bomb on the
right side and stuff yeah so like I'm
like I'll go into like an interview with
like maybe I'm not so sophisticated like
boko guy or a not so sophisticated
cartel guy and like the only word in
English that he probably knows his bomb
right he's like this dude's gonna kill
me
right it's already a sketchy situation
yeah I think they've stopped that
practice for years like they had ever
nervous were you more nervous with Boko
Haram or more nervous with the cartel
guys Boko Haram really ends down yeah
who are these guys in this picture oh so
these are the Peruvian Special Forces
they're known as the the syn chase and
there they are they are a unit devoted
completely to counter narcotics
basically that bigger is that does the
camera angle I don't think he's that big
the Peruvians in general or they're not
the Dutch
I'll say that yeah I think he's bowed
out but yeah we were we were blowing up
what are called pistas
here clandestine landing strips for the
the drug cartels oh so it was actually
really great I was helping them I mean I
wasn't helping I was advising them on
how to wire some of the charges cuz I
knew a little bit about this demolition
thing well I was helping I was helping
at all different you know the I I have
never been comfortable with the
traditional label of journalists right I
got a big fight when I was at CNN when I
was covering the
in Pakistan like a fifth of the country
was under water from these massive
floods and I was there doing
humanitarian operations and covering
them and doing a story about him but
like the the helicopters would would
land and all these desperate villagers
who hadn't had access to food or medical
supplies for weeks
they'd have 30 seconds while the bird
touchdown before they had to go to the
next spot very strict parameters for
time windows and I had a cameraman right
and Here I am I could never just be the
kind of journalist like holding a stick
mic in my hand doing nothing the hardest
thing about transitioning from the SEAL
Teams to media is I felt like I went
from being the man in the arena through
the man covering the man in the arena
and I didn't like that feeling so when I
was at CNN like yeah I picked up bags of
rice and I threw them like out the back
door because I also think my reporting
is fundamentally better and I help
people understand what's really
happening do you remember that story
about the guy in Somalia who took the
pictures of the starving man or maybe it
was a child and there was a vulture
behind him oh [ __ ] yeah I remember that
I could never do that kind of journalism
and he ended up taking pictures there
was a child that was starving and the
food tent was just over there and he
chose to take pictures and the vulture
was behind this child the child was
dying and rather than take the child and
bring him to the food Depot he kind of
allowed he just documented this case he
ended up killing himself I think yeah
shortly after actually that's that's a
much better example gonna steal that
you've had that one IP no I could never
do that [ __ ] because like I I'm more in
the George Plimpton School of Journalism
which is a obscure David reference right
it's old school right he's dead like
this dude wanted to write about the NFL
so he borrowed the yeah he boxed like he
got in the arena he like punched it out
and so if you want like clean pure
traditional objective what I would call
vulture journalism based on your last
anecdote yeah like that's not me but I
trust I trust your journalist I'm the
dude who's gonna mix it up
I trust that so much more because you're
coming into contact with objective
reality you're getting your
they are up close and personal and
you've done a lot of stuff you've been
on both sides of the doing and so for me
that's a perspective that that has a
that has layers that you're just not
going to get when you're a traditional
journalist if this is all part of this
changing world wear it wear anything
traditional is just look at where
journalism is look at where these
publications are have to do alignment
trust them I don't even trust the [ __ ]
on my phone I get this [ __ ] newsfeed
and I'm like well I'll take all of that
with a grain of salt it used to be I
believed all that [ __ ] but I'll take it
all with a grain stalk cuz then I get a
guy like you on and I'm like this
[ __ ] is this is what's really
going on like how many people actually
do that that's what's great about
podcasts was great about vice jumped
down this this was great about the show
now you're doing is the idea that you
can you can see a series on the real the
real issues the real problems behind
drug trafficking and [ __ ] like the
economy be abble on it's like a lot of
it when I hear you talk about this like
is a lot of it's like it kind of brings
you not only closer to the problem but
you identify more with it it's they're
not those bad guys over there there's
like they're guys trying to get from
point A to point B and they're taking
shortcuts but it makes sense that the
Sinaloa cartel is run by Apple because
that's the fastest way and most
efficient way to move product in and
it's a market and you're trying to make
money exactly
so exactly and and I agree my friend
amaryllis Fox who did this new series
with me she was a case officer at the
agency totally brilliant one of the
smartest people I know that one sorry
yeah I forgot we're in Hollywood come on
yeah not UTA my agency yeah they're
great they say they say I could have I
could have my CAG yeah that's Delta yes
I couldn't even been more secret
squirrel I could have said the company
my friend amber else from the company
you know right so my friend amaryllis
from who was a case officer at the
Central Intelligence Agency who did this
new drug series narco trafficking series
with me this is one of her fundamental
points and she actually did this video
for like al-jazeera or something where
they interviewed her called listening to
your enemy and she said hey my job as a
it's officer that's her that's Amma yeah
I mean what's with these women like the
hottest thing they were they stood with
a models before this on here I wait till
she hears what's going on and she was
who she worked at this agency this is
this this woman is one of the most
incredible yeah and you'll ever hear in
chime wreath yeah [ __ ] out of here
might was she was a case officer
she was a case not only was she a case
officer not to go too deep into agency
like logistics but she's she's a she she
was a knock
right so she was non-official cover so
the way intelligence training works is
you go to the farm which is where you're
trained if you're on the the do side the
Directorate of operations
the spies if you're on the spy side not
the analyst side not the techie side if
you're on the spy side you go to the
farm you get trained to be an
intelligence officer eighty percent of
the people who graduate from the farm go
to an embassy where they're under
official cover they work for the state
Department technically or in an African
embassy to do their first tour their
recruiting sources but they take a very
few people from each class and they make
them what's called a NOC non-official
cover nothing to do with the embassy
like they have their own cover story
they're way outside of the official
thing so she was Sam I was not and her
name is amaryllis Fox yeah dude I don't
want to burst your bubble like her name
may now be amaryllis Fox Kennedy she may
have hyphenated it because she's just
got married yeah let me see her husband
bring him up right [ __ ] is my buddy so
you can't you can't not [ __ ] who he is I
want to find him right now yeah open
field that's not him make sure their
wedding eyes are stuck that's a
good-looking kid he is a really good
look well of course he is of course he's
a good-looking dude oh yeah is he a big
guy the athletic he's not athletic he's
really intelligent I mean he there he is
he's he's his Bobby Kennedy's grandson
oh yeah yeah I've actually met him he's
a Malibu guy circle yeah I've met agree
did something for Bobby Kennedy so yeah
he's a good guy was a great guy was a
great guy yeah he's a good kid
alright I couldn't be happier he's
awesome they just had a baby I'm like
smiling ear-to-ear that's great yeah
he's good people yeah he was very cool
to me in fact he's great and his other
said oh he's got a brother too too -
yeah yeah yeah good guys well you know
Kennedys are a complicated family yeah
anyway that's this but I'm so Patriot so
amaryllis Fox
yeah yeah just Kennedy one of my best
friends um and she was part of the
series and and her whole concede is that
you have to listen to your enemy and if
you you know if you watch this this
video that she did it's only like five
minutes long or whatever you'll see her
discussing how she did that to recruit
her sources and it's pretty brilliant
Wow
you have to listen to your enemy what a
what a life what an amazing sort of that
sounds fascinating to me it is I mean
what an outlier she is what an outlier
oh yeah what was it do you know what it
was about her that got her to do
something that so few people do and be
effective at it yeah I don't I mean her
background is extraordinary her
intelligence and acumen is second to
none like nobody I've ever met
really oh yeah I love I love what even
when we go out at night I love how she's
got this quiet strength in that she can
dominate a room she she just somehow
like women like kind of gravitate to the
left of her like men kind of gravity
tomato dark the right of her she has
inner strength confidence and power
which is she she's able recognize that
as an undercover CIA officer she was in
the thick of it she was in these places
doing like the kind of intelligence work
that we we see in movies yeah you'll
hear more about her she's gonna be a big
star I'll introduce you guys you'll
you'll you'll dig her that she had her
on the podcast you said she's brilliant
um I'm just like an old-school
Paleolithic knuckle-dragger
Amma Amma
is brilliant you're falsely modest but I
appreciate that no one knuckle dragger
to it other your I love I love
complicated people which is where you
are in the best way dude thanks for
coming on man this is this was epic look
at this this comfortable studio I took
over for Shah Baba
yeah he's literally lost his voice he
goes dude I can't speak that's it I'll
take it from here he goes really you can
you do so longer yeah it's raining don't
worry about it yeah so he's that guy
needs to take a break nobody burns it
nobody burns it at both ends like shop
really yeah he's got it he's got it
relax well this is the butter and the
kid with Kosh larson Navy SEAL war
correspondent TV producer TV creator
surfer and barrel-chested man who's
impervious to the cold and fear we're
out yeah I'm just gonna record that for
my answering service the last ten
seconds like when people call me that's
what it's gonna be is my face all marked
up my can look like an ass on camera or
this hit we didn't do current events I
don't know if you guys even need it but
if you guys want see we can do it what
do we got for gonna bass let's go
through it before we can you splice in
the part Ryan of course anything you
want yeah yeah yeah just give me a
little brief like we're just gonna go
over stories but sure yeah so I'll just
spices in so now cool corey feldman
defense Michael Jackson after leaving
Neverland says singer never touched me
inappropriately this guy is always
looking for attention corey feldman he's
such a mess I by the way I haven't seen
leaving Neverland but I had some people
hit me up on DMS about because I went
hard in the paint about the accuser is
not coming forward when they could have
but one of them was 15 so I don't know
and I don't know enough about this but
but then I talked to a really well-known
songwriter who's a famous songwriter who
knows a lot of people in the business
including all the people around him and
he goes there is no doubt in my mind and
then you look at the details of Michael
Jackson hey bro what were you doing
hanging out with 8 year old kids and why
were you separating the parents and why
were you staying in a hotel room with
them and all that stuff what the [ __ ] is
really going on so III have to assume
Bay I haven't seen me believe in never I
have to assume that there's something
fishy going on and maybe this
[ __ ] was a true pedophile right
no I don't know yeah but but Corey
Feldman is is coming out saying the
memories were fun maybe they were yeah
well Corey Feldman is one of a couple
celebrities who hung out with Michael
Jackson when they were younger who said
that they've personally never had
anything weird happen with Michael it
seems to be a select few kids who've had
that experience and then a couple of
others who have it like I think Macaulay
Culkin also a child that hung out with
Michael Jackson quite a bit when he was
doing his home alone stage of life he
didn't get anything he's actually the
godfather of Paris Jackson and so it
seems like he's saying that there's
nothing he's not saying that these
things didn't happen just that they
didn't happen to him
we know that did Paris Jackson he's not
a kid lay no they're not his biological
children right isn't it his semen or
something
no apparently it's not apparently we
don't know no apparently according to
this this very famous musician I was
talking to he's like no like secrets
well no it's it's no matter that the
sperm was belongs to what's-his-name
there's a he's a dermatologist or he's
uh he's yeah I think it's dermatologists
so it's not his biological kids because
Michael Jackson was black and this kids
are you know why are Michael Jackson's
kids white there's a rumor that his
father castrated him when he was younger
in order to keep his voice so high yeah
so what do you be able to impregnate
people if so anyway apparently
apparently these were not his biological
because she's white guys she's not black
that's her yeah that's the daughter it's
a white girl okay
she looks pretty that's a white girl
it's not a black girl Michael Jackson
was a black man so that's a white girl I
love how people just don't want to call
they don't want to see what's really
going on hmm
and doesn't mean that he didn't love her
and doesn't mean she doesn't consider
him her father and doesn't mean that
that it's not his daughter for all
intents and purposes I don't mean to
like you know but just interesting to me
the dock is four hours long I got to see
what yeah it was that Sundance and I was
there for the other film and people went
to see it apparently most of the people
left after the two-hour intermission not
because not because it was bad they said
it's from a film perspective X these are
all like film nerds right they said it's
excellent but they said like no I just
couldn't listen to another two hours
about MJ molesting oh that's why I think
we're tortured by it by the way one of
his well did you like it so all right
that's it ready all right
I believe blanket was the one that he
held outside of the window infamously
dude I wasn't sure yeah oh yeah maybe
okay that was it so house there are an
extraordinary number of people in this
town I'd like to punch in the face just
because of their just to button down
they just they're just too happy with
their haircuts and I'm talking about the
guys that's why I'm a member
Browns I can go there and be angry
listen there are a lot of effective
people there but yeah though okay well
yeah I don't think they have Michael's
DNA but that's okay who cares
yeah it's tough for them how about that
how about it I it's tough for those kids
in a lot of ways any easy all right
um next one yeah all right so the second
man ever who was infected by who has HIV
is currently in remission and is off of
medication for I believe a year and a
half and where he had the same type of
treatment that the first guy who was
cured of HIV had it's a special element
all right yeah he had a bone they both
had I think leukemia and they had a bone
marrow transplant and so
with a with a there's a protein that I
guess the HIV virus uses to enter the
cell and there's a mutation of that
protein called like CF 65 or something
and when you have that mutation you you
are HIV resistant but this is incredible
to me because at 52 our monet's was a
death sentence and I had people I knew
fairly well who died of this disease and
saw it up close and personal and it was
such a terrifying disease because you
died of starvation actually you had
horrible lesions on your face and you
had just a system-wide attack it was
such a shitty way to go and it was a
death sentence and you get it and you'd
be HIV positive and you would have to
just wait until the inevitable happen
you start getting colds and flus that
would never go away and then skin things
and all kinds of awful stuff your body
couldn't take food it was just the worst
thing in the world so this is incredible
to me this is like this is we cured Hep
C and we might be on the verge of curing
aids that's not not putting in a
remission but curing it that's
incredible amazing it is incredible so
so anybody who has a problem with
Western medicine and you think that all
doctors and the medical industry is just
and Big Pharma is just all bad go [ __ ]
yourself and go into a lab because now
this stuff is a lot of this is there a
lot of private labs are working really
hard and coming up with ways to solve
these problems because there's a lot of
money in it so this is where the
marketplace is doing a great job by the
way straight outta Africa so HIV is one
of these diseases that emerged from the
Congo River Basin at some point jump the
air gap between humans people and
animals monkeys whatever yeah yes I was
I was in Liberia covering the Ebola
crisis and same thing it was like how it
jumps the air gap and epidemiologists
who are miracle workers have traced not
only did they trace the epidemiology of
the Ebola outbreak in West Africa and
Liberia the last time around but they've
done incredible stuff around HIV and and
patient zero with HIV apparently a
flight attendant flying around the world
watched the outbreaks go so it's amazing
that we are on the cusp of do you okay
you've been you've seen some
[ __ ] West Africa and the Ebola you just
go to the craziest places you've seen
some [ __ ] dude I met this dude they
calls himself the virus hunter he goes
deep in the jungles looking for the next
HIV and in viola he's quiet
that dude's crazy jealous of the way you
live your life I love my life but you're
a bad [ __ ] dude he just goes
Liberia by the way how about that
country oh how about that disaster
Liberia is unbelie-- acute Charles
Taylor and Foday Sankoh yeah well run
Sierra Leone these days they still love
Charles there's a lot of Charles Taylor
loyalists I was there in uniform also
training the Liberian Special Forces one
of the best things ever I was there to
teach them combat diving right very like
esoteric art of warfare and I showed up
and they had this like brand-new dive
facility that the Israelis had built
them perfect equipment never even been
open still had like the tags on it and I
was like oh okay like where's where's
the pool will start our combat diving
training and they're like oh well this
way and we ran to like this Lake and I
was like this is the pool they're like
oh yeah we don't have a pool so they
wanted me to like build a combat diving
program crocodiles there was definitely
[ __ ] crocodiles in the lake but it
didn't matter because the Liberian dudes
that I was supposed to teach combat
diving too didn't know how to swim
so I basically like taught them like the
only thing I did for my six weeks there
was teach them like a little bit of
swimming in the lake and that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you're going to the lake in
Liberia there are crocodiles it's not
like a an agency that keeps it crocodile
free no no you don't get into a lake in
a success you get in the lake and havoc
on the lake yeah Jesus Christ they told
me there was no crocodiles well I don't
feel [ __ ] know they're not crocodile
ologists all right man you're reckless I
gotta have a talk with you you're being
too reckless all right and you got Ebola
and crocodiles [ __ ] Cod I just called
him Andy
gosh alright so this is going viral
right now it was posted by Sports Center
by the way what's up yeah because take a
look at how fast he is
this is ridiculous right but they
reposted it from a boxing official
Instagram handle and they put down that
he was still 52 and able to do this
right yeah unfortunately it's not that
but this is when he was filming a movie
for Steven Segal and it was like the
movie came out in 2017 so this is
probably around 2016 ish which is still
amazing it also means that my test will
kick your this is incredibly fast yeah
it's freaking amazing how about that
guys look at his hands BJ yes
you want to [ __ ] around yeah that's
that's that's that's Mike Tyson like
David Blaine tells me this hilarious
story about how he wanted to see if he
could last three rounds with Mike Tyson
so David Blaine started training David
Blaine's never boxed in his life and he
went to I think was Teddy Alice and and
he goes I want to I want to try to last
three rounds and and Teddy Atlas son was
like what's that what's the trick and he
goes there's no trick I just want to get
good enough and he goes well that's not
gonna happen this lifetime and he
couldn't get anybody anybody to do it
like every trainer was like no you're
not that's not possible bro you can
never do that you will never do that so
he didn't understand boxing or like you
know combat sorry so he trained for nine
months and I he found the guy he gave
him like a hundred grand and he got into
the ring with David I'm sorry if I'm
butchering the story but he got into the
ring and with a cruiserweight who was
like just a good kind of semi good
professional and David said he got
jabbed once and he went holy [ __ ]
and then he goes all right just get up
he fell down get up try it again he gets
anything he gets Chad they're gonna go
oh [ __ ] they he took the head he took
the head gear of all his gloves because
I can't do this he was we've been
telling you that no hold up that was a
jab he goes that was a cruiser way if
Mike Tyson decided to hit you this was
back in like 2003 or something he was
you you would be it would take
oneexchange and guys who don't have
never done that with a real pro don't
understand them it's what I go back to
it's like do you think you're a tough
guy you're not you're not it's just
you're just not sorry oh my god I love
that I mean Bob like okay like when you
get jabbed by a large cruiserweight some
dudas you know 6 2 and walks around the
2
fifteen but sucks damn that 188 do you
know how hard he's gonna jab do you know
what happens to your face when you're a
right and put all we gotta tell you what
I'll give you a head gear and I'll give
you a bar got no problem see what
happens you're gonna go out it's a good
chance you can knock the [ __ ] out but
you're definitely not gonna want to
fight again you're gonna get hit that
hard with a jab forget it right it's a
nightmare
if you although realize how hard those
guys who've been throwing a right hand
their whole life it's a different thing
I'm moving around with Wayne McCulloch
who's five six 135 I have no business
doing it but well yesterday we're
[ __ ] around and I'm not my head gear
on I'm trying to do this like this
pattern and stuff like that where hit
and it gets you know which we start
moving around he's hitting me
he's bigger than that he's just doing
that not he but my face is all marked up
and I'm [ __ ] like if he had started
opening up but won't would he dug into
my wrist but I had to he just got under
my elbow a little bit and I was like oh
that's a disaster and he was being nice
that's 135 pound man good luck with a
dude who's good luck with a guy who's
[ __ ] anything over 160 you're going
to sleep you're going to sleep yeah I
don't think age to a degree is the
limiting factor Randy Couture right
he'll go yeah look at him he'll get the
show yeah you don't Chuck like I'm
buddies with Chuck like like and Chuck's
like Chuck's broken he's hurt yeah but
like he hits hard yeah he hits free yeah
oh hey Bry what do you do box shut up I
wrestle in high school what shut up you
know that's different Lister it's a very
different it's a very different thing
yeah another one yeah alright this is
becoming a weird trend but parents are
throwing cheese at their babies faces
because of this one video that actually
got wet viral I'll show you this one
it's just so it seems harmless right
yeah but yeah but all these parents are
doing it now and I guess people are
starting to like say is this not cool to
do I mean you know it's iffy
it is if you're right borderline it's
all good you know what you guys mess
with your kids you can want your kid to
grow up like cash Larson then hit him in
the face with cheese if not then baby
and coddle him because I guarantee gosh
a lot of cheese on his face awesome
hilarious they have no idea what's going
on by the way it's delicious yeah I
think this girl just caught on her face
and started eating it catch it yeah
anyways there's a bunch of those um one
more yeah
how about this this is not that current
it's like a week or two but once again a
Chinese person threw coins into a jet
engine for good luck
this is like the third time it's
happened can't do that and yeah this
guy's being sued he's only 28 years old
so he should know better by now he's
also taking a ton of rhino horn so he
had a hard-on as well yeah cuz that [ __ ]
works I don't care what the Saturday
right every time I ingest rhino horn and
I can [ __ ] all night look at that yeah I
can't believe it's still happening good
for some coins into the older people I
understand the other ones like grandma's
like they're just old thinking yeah this
guy's 28 so he's getting sued by them
this this is like the [ __ ] that wins the
Darwin Award right now yeah yeah the
Darwin Awards are great it was like the
guy the guy two guys who held a
rattlesnake down with a loaded shotgun
with the button of a loaded shotgun the
rattlesnake wrapped it's you know all in
and I just pulled the trigger and blew
the [ __ ] guy's head off although
truth be told there was social media
when you and I are growing up we
probably would have been eligible for a
few Darwin's 100% I did a lot of dumb
[ __ ] I came I came to that party
thinking I knew all the play you know
they'd certain truths that you think are
you know that's not true
like piranhas I thought piranhas
actually ate people and you swim among
them they you don't they don't I also
believed in that that theme is funded up
the ticket doesn't exist it's not true
no it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's never
hate sure its legend but it's I don't
know well it's a mystery doesn't swim up
your Pisa and open Barb's in your dick
that's not true that's folklore and
piranhas when you're swimming among them
don't skeletonize you
they don't do that this is great news
because I always wanted to either surf
that River wave in the Amazon that
people do or I've always only one dude
has ever swam the Panama Canal from the
Pacific to our sorry from the Atlantic
to the Pacific side I always wanted to
do that there might be some crocodiles
but there are my heard about the Nile
crocodiles and saltwater crocodiles but
you don't want to [ __ ] around Crocs I
would be worried about that but I think
the Amazon only has caiman I don't think
they have Crocs the Panama Canal
definitely asked Crocs because I've seen
them in there so I know that that's a
little harder but I was less worried
about the Crocs and more worried about
the mythological fish I was like I'm
gonna have to swim this thing with a
condom on you're fine okay swim with a
condom on anyway you can buy get
chlamydia is probably the [ __ ] waters
turn is that it
do you want this one you could [ __ ] yeah
I do all right so I guess Hillary
Clinton says she's not running in 2020
it didn't work oh wait and it didn't
work in [ __ ] like give it up but look
at how they're tweeting to each other
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton so
Donald Trump tweets this you want to
read it crooked Hillary confirmed she
will not run in 2020 rules out a third
date for the White House aw shucks
does that mean I won't get to run
against her she will be sorely missed
the President of the United States and
then her she she does a meme of Mean
Girls on her Twitter why are you so
obsessed with me how crazy is this well
she's got people doing this but I love
but still oh it's amazing no it's not
it's si this is not about politics I
[ __ ] hate Twitter I know you're I
know you're huge on Twitter I know
you're I can't I hate Twitter all of it
it's mean
so bad play sucks it's worse than it's
worse than the war it's worse than the
war zones you've been in seriously it is
there's a lot more frag incoming I'll
tell you that it's all about [ __ ]
destruction yeah it's not about anything
other than destruction it's just it's
just gossip [ __ ] tribal horseshit
and people are just like man you know in
the immortal words of Stuart it's bad
for America
damn right brother it's bad for America
it's bad for us that's it
Karl arson we should like it keep all of
this yeah for sure
gosh this finally we did we did our I'm
looking at Bella Hadid tiny white tank
top right there
oh look bring it up just because I need
some photographers alright yeah yeah I
appreciate that that's a good look I
really do it's a fantastic look Kasia
I'm gonna go home and hang my PUD is
that image I want to thank you brother
for don't-don't-don't it's that it is a
war zone but don't don't capture that on
your camera thank you casual arson
thanks for joining the fighter in the
kid the mother of all podcast this is
the fighter in a kid we're out